sadiq al-mahdi came from a family of
religious and political figures
his grandfather was the leader of the
movement to end the british occupation
mahdi led sudan for two terms in the
1960s and 80s
he was removed both times by military
coups as sudan buckled under the
pressure
of religious linguistic and cultural
divisions
a civil war in the south led to a famine
that claimed hundreds of thousands of
lives
after his second term ended in 1989 omar
al-bashir ran the country for almost
30 years but only with the threat and
use
of brutal military power throughout
mahdi continued to lead the opposition
umma party against bashir
although often from outside the country
and when economic hardship spit he was
quick to back protests against bashir's
government
in 2014 mahdi was arrested accused of
conspiring with armed rebels
a charge that carried the death penalty
he spent time in self-exile in cairo
but returned to sudan greeted by large
crowds
ahead of another mass uprising over
crippling food and fuel prices in 2018.
[Music]
the most important demand is that this
regime must leave and be replaced
by a transitional national government
whose duty is to achieve
peace and human rights and liberties the
government must implement an economic
program
that will relieve the suffering of the
people a reform program
and a national conference to draft the
constitution
the protests eventually led to the
ousting and jailing of omar al-bashir
for corruption
mahdi then pushed for a transfer to
civilian rule
political active until the pandemic
arrived almaty tested positive for
covert 19.
he was taken to the united arab emirates
for treatment but succumbed to the virus
he will be remembered as a leader of
sudan's largest political party
and sudan's last democratically elected
prime minister